now it's time to raise money for the
internal Butler and you've said already
that possibly the budget will be 5
million how do we find investors for the
film
I think ultimately a film like this
needs to find
I think it would be depending I think it
actually could be a combination of
things it could be because of the fact
that it is like if we decide if we just
want to set it in Europe
uh then we could go to some place like
Ireland or Greece or wherever we decide
it is it has a good
film
you know encouragement program and see
what those things would do so that would
be the first thing I would do is I would
look at what could what how do I make
the package better
how do I make it something that it's
hard for you to say no to anybody can
just put together a package and put
together a budget and say this is how
much it's going to cost
that's not a production plan a
production plan is when you go in and
you look at all those elements and you
say you know if I did this and I did
this and maybe I did this and maybe I
figured out how to do this and then I go
shoot it here then I could actually make
this movie look like it's worth
eight million dollars or ten million
dollars for five million dollars
that's how something like the Matrix
gets done because Joel Silver is smart
enough to go well one I got these two
guys who have never done anything except
for now the movie I had them do that was
successful which I can bound right
they've never done anything before that
which he got them to do so that they
could do that and then what he did was
he went and he found he did it in I
believe New Zealand uh and figured and
got a better production package so got
the effects cheaper with a new effects
company so it made essentially put
together a package where doing those
other two films and that were
essentially the cost of one film and all
those films were cheaper than any film
that would have been made in the United
States
so that's how we got the studios to do
it he he now because he had to get
around the fact that he had these two
guys he'd never really done anything
except for bound now who've written this
great sci-fi thing and he's still Joel
Silver but he's still got to convince
them to do it it's not just like they're
just gonna roll out and then you still
may only have one person who wants to do
it in these levels of doing these tiers
so one having a package that is
undeniable that is something that says
it's like I figured this out I thought
this out so thoroughly that you are just
you know you just do I am the package
it's not the package that speaks to it's
like I am the package you know I was
like I'm the captain now you know like
if you have that feeling with it when
selling something that's your best
chance of getting the money for it
uh I whatever it is you know it it's
just the ability to put yourself in that
and that that ultimately that person is
investing in you
uh ultimately that your ability to
execute it
you know so they're yes they want that
movie but they want that movie that's
the Sean Reed movie
you know if that's production quality if
that's good storytelling whatever that
is that's what they that's what they now
they've decided they want
so how do you make sure you convince
them of that
checking every single every single check
mark off over and over again knowing
exactly having thought about it in
multiple ways and having also basically
the the gumption to say I'm going to
make this no matter what whether you
give me this money or not I'm gonna make
it
you know so if you want to get on board
right
you know that's fine too see you later
bye
it's just that simple because when you
do that you're in control of the process
much more as much as you can possibly be
because you're not nobody is but ick
Lisa gives you an opportunity to give
yourself the takeaway you're taking it
away before because that makes people
want nobody wants to be sold everybody
wants to buy
right no it wants to be sold but
everybody wants to buy so how do you
make that that's you can't have it
look at this can't happen
mine all mine sorry oh mine can't have
it that's the only thing you got
so working that and and proceeding as if
and working in that way is the only way
that I've ever known how to do things
and either gotten money or gotten people
to give me money or gotten investors or
gotten things is by almost an almost
like hard-headedness of like I'm going
to do it and I'll do it no matter what
and that
energy is what people want to get on
board with whatever that is you've got
to imagine Henry Ford felt exactly like
that he was going to do he's going to do
a matter what you know it has to be that
energy I think in that thinking
especially these days getting movies
done it's
anyway
so if there you come in with maybe too
much desperation
it's it's definitely going to turn
people off even if you don't have the
five million yeah it's not about that's
why I'm bringing other elements I'm
bringing the plan I'm bringing the movie
I'm bringing the we're going to shoot it
in Greece and I've already talked to
them and I got in the vet and this is
the plan we're going to get back and
this is the money we're going to get
back when you give me that money
so every when I have that type of plan
just like any other startup
you know if you want to look at it that
way pull it back to that what everyone's
doing a startup or whatever a movie is
essentially a startup
every single movie is a startup
it has to convince
multiple individuals that it should
exist and then be able to convince many
many many many more individuals that it
should exist to be successful
and it either came and is an IP it will
it can earn money for the rest of its
life
as for the every year it can make a
little bit make a little bit of money
you can make something every single year
for the rest of its life if it starts to
if it you know gets in the right
position if the per if the person taking
care of their startup
their little baby if they raise it up
right it could actually turn into
something that actually gives you money
back every single year imagine that
something that earns money
um but it is a it's a tenuous process
process to get from that a to movie
how are you contacting potential
investors
what are you telling me
it really depends on the circumstances
um you know like in the most recent
circumstances is like hey this is almost
done this is what I need I kind of
warned you I may be calling you for it
and uh let's do this and then it's done
in two days those are usually the best
way that these deals get done I've
primed somebody in the past
um for a circumstance or in that in a
window and I know that the money is
there
and you know you just close the deal
um when you're really mining you know
for new prospects uh it starts to be a
different type of game
um at this point me personally I'm doing
a combination of things you know I'm
looking at
who do I know and who do I know no who
do they know right and who do who can I
ask you know or who can put me in front
of that person that can ultimately do
that
um
fortunately I'm in you know my other
businesses now put me in partnership
with people who have put me in those
types of things and that other business
puts me in a position where someone gave
me a significant amount of money to
build that so it gives me more
opportunities to find people to do that
than I did than I had
even six months ago or a year ago
um so it's just
some of it is just really knowing what
that person wants and knowing if that
person is appropriate I may know plenty
of people who would be right for the
projects that I'm interested in because
those are people that I've found for
those projects
uh this specific project our internal
Butler I've never even thought about
doing a movie like this in the in the
region I have something that is a pure
piece that is set in the 70s that I am
working on so there is some relatable
things but this movie is still my movie
is much more of something you've never
seen before which gives you that ability
to want people to see it just because
you mean you mean this story happened
and nobody's ever talked about it you
know yes no one's ever talked about
really we've got to make a movie about
it you've got to make that movie so it
has that gotta make that movie feel
where this one has I think needs another
element to make it which probably would
be a script that would be really
right and then an actor to put in that
was going to make it that's a movie we
got to see
so it needs a few more elements in its
package before it gets me to be like
does the movie Gotta See
like especially when you work off of
character-driven things that's the
difference when you work off of if you
work off a plot and you work off of that
then you can sell you're selling a
concept
first time AI talks well the investor
sees that they either one or their one
let's go back and look at some of these
other ones we were talking about so we
had an aging Butler reminiscing about
their Glory Days so that's a very
internal driven kind of story and then
we had a small Mouse with a big heart
one is that an animated movie
if it's an animated movie that's
expensive
really expensive
if it's not an animated movie then it's
a really inexpensive cheap movie and I
really don't like making like movies
that like what I'm gonna go run around
and try to like travel a little mouse
underneath the thing it becomes a really
cheap movie
right you can only make this movie one
or two ways
because of what it is but how it's been
described I mean one you're talking
about an animal one way or another you
gotta have an animal Wrangler
it's either it's animation or it's
something so that one's that's all
concept though like I you could go in
there and say yeah because I'm going to
have CGI or I've come up with a new
camera to shoot a real live mouse and
now we're gonna put a mouthpack on it
you got to figure that out how are you
going to make that movie so that's like
just like weird putting the money into
developing the story of the movie before
you can really even develop the story
you have to develop a kind of scope you
can work under to write an appropriate
story to go along with script
right if not you're wasting your time
so a lifelong bachelor well that's also
one of those that could be just about
anything and really that's
character to me
interior at the club a lifelong bachelor
that's so vague
right I mean really that's that could be
anything a lifelong bachelor gets shot
at a club movie over
okay the World's phone set me uh
interior top secret facility the world's
first sent me an AI well we've seen this
on some level
um and we know that it's not going to be
cheap I mean we all know this right and
if it is cheap do you want to see it
no probably not interior arcade a video
game character comes to life well that's
not original because we've already got
Wreck-It Ralph and Wreck-It Ralph 2 and
several other movies Tron so it's not a
concept that you haven't seen before you
know so it's not original not unless we
find a video character comes to life and
perhaps
well that doesn't even work because I
think that just happened in that last
one that I just saw where the character
fell in love with a human character the
human character fell in love with the so
yeah that's see already been made so
once again expensive probably big studio
in terms of
what we've got so sweet spot like there
were two of them that were and really
the one I was kind of pushing the corner
with the with the butler by the way
I just think that was the best choice
for me well and also too if the
character is likable even if there are
moments in the beginning let's say where
were put off by him but if there's
something we're drawn to where we have
some kind of empathy maybe we see that
this man has just given away his entire
life to this family and we start to see
that this family maybe isn't that good
if maybe there's some elements to them
that are not honorable and uh then he
finds out this secret and he's kind of
like what am I doing this for
yeah I mean it gives it gives a lot of
you know because it just gives it to me
this feels like the beginning of a movie
these all feel like essentially plot
line description character descriptions
of within a context like a movie about
at a club a lifelong bachelor okay
that's fine to me but discovers a
terrible yeah wait a minute world's
first sent me an AI That's plot right
even though it's
character but that's the character but
to me that's actually really the plot
because it's the world's first set in
the AI it's the character but it's also
the plot
because that's what happens the world
first setting Ai and now that's his
Consciousness that's the plot too to me
guess no maybe yeah right
yeah it sees how you see how it kind of
pushes you to one side already where we
had so many more options with
with our aging Butler reminiscing
right and and we can we can imagine a
lot of scenarios where maybe he's not
really seen us who he is because maybe a
lot of the people that he waits on look
down on him but he's actually much more
than well and you can certainly like
what asking
I think the reason I love movies
personally
um and I've always loved movies and
being involved in them in any kind of
way is because they ask what if
um and just like the great scientists
and the great people in medicine and
great other ways we are able to ask
ourselves what if
and
why limit ourselves
to that question it's the most beautiful
question what if
because
there are no limitations to that where
the average person or the average
Storyteller or the Storyteller who
hasn't
started to challenge themselves we'll
take that and just do that
I'm just going to do it in in the
backyard and that's what they're going
to do where we've gone and now he's gone
crazy and he's left and he's now in a
hotel and he's teaching people and he's
wandering the world like Kung Fu or
whatever it is because we're willing to
ask
what if